merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur depuis des
semaines plusieurs quartiers de
Marseille mais aussi d'autres secteurs
d'autres métropoles comme Nantes sont
victimes d'une véritable conquête de
territoire par des trafiquants de drogue
mais aussi le crime organisé certains de
ces habitants des quartiers cités ce
sont même mobilisés pour essayer
d'empêcher l'installation du trafic et
également protéger leur famille en se
relayant jour et nuit
alors comment en sommes-nous arrivés là
Monsieur le Ministre comment des
quartiers autrefois tranquilles se sont
transformés en moins d'une génération en
Chicago sur Rhône ou Bronx sur Loire
quand des citoyens on viennent à voir ce
protéger par eux-mêmes c'est le début
d'une lente déconstruction du processus
de civilisation
l'état recul les lois de la République
s'effacent et la loi du plus fort
s'impose à tous ce que subissent ces
habitants de ce ministre c'est à la fois
les conséquences de l'explosion de la
délinquance des mineurs l'effondrement
de la chaîne pénale la surpopulation
carcérale et également la banalisation
de la drogue la drogue justement voilà
le cœur du problème et seul la fermeté
la guerre contre ce fléau sans relâche
pourra régler définitivement ce problème
alors monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur êtes-vous prêt véritablement
amener cette guerre